- [Narrator] The village
of Kamikatsu is special.
Not for its tea fields
or idyllic mountains
or peaceful historic homes.
It's known for something it doesn't have.
Kamikatsu, as a town,
produces almost no trash.
Kamikatsu has a population
of roughly 1,500 people
and in the 1990s was
doing nearly no recycling.
(foreign language)
Burning all that garbage
created carbon dioxide omissions
that became dangerous,
and the nature around them
was suffering, so a decision was made.
Kamikatsu had to change.
This was the start of their
path toward zero waste
and a new way of living.
(foreign language)
Effectively, what zero waste here means
is that there's no such thing
as throwing something in the trash.
Everything has to get recycled.
And in the beginning, it
was difficult for everyone.
Like Mr. Takuya Takeichi.
He's shop owner in Kamikatsu.
(foreign language)
And Mrs. Hachie Katayama.
She's a housewife.
(foreign language)
That classification
system she's talking about
is the key to Kamikatsu's
success, and it is aggressive.
There are 45 categories of recyclables.
(foreign language)
The list, it goes on; there's 35 more.
Slowly, what was
originally this huge burden
became a way of life in Kamikatsu.
People began looking at trash differently.
(foreign language)
It's important to recognize
that Kamikatsu is a small town.
It is not like New York or London.
The rules are not the same,
but there is a constant,
and that's people; they can change.
(foreign language)